we have our celebrity bracket challenge
and we also have Chris Mannix in the
bracket challenge as well the Sports
Illustrated senior writer NBC Sports
Boston NBA analyst when did you hear
that you were being a topic of
conversation on the program yesterday I
had a handful of tweets that that didn't
make sense without context and then I
heard from Fritzie after the fact that
it was a topic of conversation so I went
back and listened you guys are a bunch
of jerks I I didn't request to be in
this bracket I didn't know was a
celebrity bracket Fritzie had texted me
a few days ago about filling one out I
did that and you know Perloff why I know
is is a jerk I know he was first on
board Paulie didn't defend me despite
our longstanding friendship and I
thought that was uh just overall
uncalled for on the show yesterday
now fritzy considers you a celebrity I
mean if there's a lot of people
celebrities doesn't mean no no not only
celebrity but his families but he's
filled in so many times that guest host
has been with us practically since day
one how could we not include him to
photo Brack okay man it would have been
worth it like if I had if you know
texted fritzy or Perloff or a say like
can I get in on this I'm I'm really
feeling my bracket and won't get on this
that's one thing but I was asked to fill
in a bracket and all of a sudden I hear
Perloff rattling off names of you know
real celebrities and lumping me get into
the mix like which of these names does
not belong in America I see how it is no
you know who started it
it was McLovin yeah well I have no doubt
and I was just going with the flow of it
because it was good contact because I I
said no and then I immediately said
let's have Mannix on and I want to talk
basketball with what McLovin remember
and you see I said hey why don't we take
Mannix out and put in Bleacher Report's
Howard back and you're like no let's I
thought that that was mean-spirited
writers then McLovin goes well Howard
Becks
than mannix and i said where's his
coming from
you know what would stuck worse though I
mean Polly said put whoa Jim that was
you know a knife to the heart wait till
we get what we tried we did try to get
watch everything we couldn't get it we
tried for Dan Bickley as well we
couldn't get all right Doc Rivers said
I'm staying with the Clippers as long as
they'll have me there was some chatter I
I don't even know if they were rumors
but Doc Rivers may be going to the
Lakers was there anything to that story
no because I mean look there were there
were rumors in the last offseason that
doc was going to get a extension done
he's got a very strong relationship with
Steve Ballmer and and likes working
there so clearly those rumors were true
with the the backroom dealing that that
doc had with with Steve Ballmer and it's
just I think all things being equal
knowing Doc Rivers he would be
interesting coaching the Lakers but
they're not equal I mean he's going to
get a massive financial deal from the
Clippers and they're in a really good
place whereas if you look across the
hall I don't know what place the Lakers
are in I don't know what their path to
contending for a championship is with
LeBron at the stage of his career so all
those things factored in I think that
was just sort of connecting dots of Doc
Rivers LeBron James to player and coach
that could coexist and frankly damn it
there aren't a lot of guys that you
would say you know can coexist at at a
high level with LeBron that's another
thing because there was a quote that
said that LeBron this was an anonymous
quote that you know that doc would not
take the Lakers job because LeBron quote
doesn't want to be coached this at this
point in his career
I don't know that he doesn't want to be
coached I think that there are you have
to have a certain level of gravitas I
think to to be able to coach LeBron and
to be able to get through to him
Erik Spoelstra had that gravitas in part
because yet the the full backing of Pat
Riley yeah but since then I mean you
know tyloo you know he was the preferred
choice of LeBron but I don't know how
much coaching you know he did individual
coach he did of LeBron out there there
really haven't been too many in LeBrons
history that have you know kind of
coached him so there's only a handful of
guys than that that really have the the
ability to do that yeah I'm just trying
to figure that in that if you got Doc
Rivers because I don't know if LeBron is
attracting free agents Doc Rivers might
help you and I thought it would be a
brilliant business move by the Lakers if
they got Doc because you are you you
sting the crosstown or you know cross
staples tenants with the Clippers and
you get a great coach Hall of Fame coach
and then you're gonna get him and maybe
you got some free agents who would want
to play under him realizing that he
might be running the team as opposed to
if tyronn lue comes in or Brian Shaw
then LeBron is probably still running it
but who's if you look at these two teams
who has a better future the Clippers are
the Lakers you know as hard as it is to
say that a team with LeBron doesn't have
the better future you're pretty
hard-pressed to not look at what the
Clippers are doing and and what they
have in terms of flexibility and the
likelihood too that they're gonna be the
team this offseason that makes the major
splash I don't know if the Clippers get
Kawhi Leonard but there's certainly a co
favorite to do that I do believe there
will be strong interest from Kevin
Durant to play for the Clippers this
summer though most people believe that
the Knicks are if it's not Golden State
the Knicks are the front-runner whereas
if you look at the Lakers and I think
we've talked about this a bit before you
know the top-tier free agents they don't
they aren't listing least not privately
from what I'm told they're not listing
the Lakers as their preferred choice now
L
I could turn around and you know pay
boogie cousins whenever he wants to be
paid and you certainly could get him to
come down there but does that push you
closer to a championship and you know
cousins coming off the injury is he
going to be that same franchise player
he looked like at the end of his time in
New Orleans it's tough and you know the
clock is ticking on LeBron and you know
I don't know if this this injury
suffered this year is a precursor to
others it's been that way in the past
you know for some players Kobe Bryant
included so I think you'd have to say
you know looking at it objectively that
the Clippers are the team in LA with the
brighter future Chris it's great to talk
to you and I hope you enjoy your
celebrity bracket challenge do I get
anything if I win what do you want Chris
I should be able to like dictate for a
day what the Dan Nets have to wear on
the show if you win okay now what did
the dance get if you don't win I'd leave
that up to them okay Paulie mohawk know
the last time we cut Mannix's hair it
was short for the first night and not
poofy for the first time his life he's
sticking with the short hair we did the
guy in favor that's fair I would agree
with that that's fair yeah your
girlfriend thanked us because we gave
you a better look
mohawk is a bad look though bad look
well you had Moe from the Three Stooges
there for a while that haircut okay we
don't need what is within reason for you
guys that you can if Mannix doesn't win
because he said I'm winning your stupid
bracket challenge yes Pauline I hit so
something has to wear I don't know him
we can we can come up with it a small
Boston Celtics vintage Jersey and shorts
size small that's not that's the first
thing came to my mind he loves the
Celtics oh hey Jenny button McLovin you
got one I like it but he has to wear
like your Larry Bird outfitted grownups
yes to wear for a whole three hour show
and when he sits in the chair
black shoes black hi Tom she looks like
a Celtic yeah you do
you're like Scott Wedman I would have
gone more you know Chris Guccione
for me Conner Henry how's that great I
want Gordon Hayward hair is what I want
oh man yeah
going to impeccable Gordo's movable yeah
he's done well yeah done well in the
hair department alright we'll come up
with something aromatics but if you
happen to win the bracket challenge and
you can you can rough up the dance then
and I'm not if you look at my bracket
I'm not going shocked I'm outside the
box all over the place who'd you pick I
did pick Duke to win but I'm in the
Final Four think you just went out of
the box and then you just went back in
the box
wow you're crazy you picked Duke you're
crazy
besides Duke okay
and who else did you pick in your phone
for I think I've Nevada in the Final
Four
there's one other team that's like it I
get the 12 seed to make the Final Four
loss alone would you Buffalo in there
there are the elite eight I believe okay
all right well thank you Chris you got a
death that's uh Chris Mannix for more
Dan Patrick show to the audience channel
239 on DirecTV or download the Dan
Patrick show app
[Music]